he is
attached to that story that made no
sense you just said you choked I would
have to say about if I was to find God
it would have to be Vias
I think it's the last religion on the
planet
that's the right religion I think it's
the last religion so if it's if it's the
last True Religion on the planet then it
has to be the corrector
[Music]
if you want to look at countries I'd
love to actually do this study maybe you
know better than me but if you were to
look at countries in terms of police
expenditure to Crime I would I would
guarantee that the Islamic countries the
ones we just talked about the first
world ones are some of the safest
countries on Earth per capita for the
amount of money they spend trying to
police crime whereas in other countries
we're just spending unlimited money
trying to stop crime We Can't Stop women
don't respect men anymore men don't
really want the women besides for a
one-night stand no one's having children
no one's having families no one's
satisfied or fulfilled which is why they
want to take drugs and do stupid things
and degenerate themselves and everything
spirals into the other right humans need
higher purpose and and this is the thing
I'll be completely honest with you my
friend I was an atheist for a long time
I I really was I was an 80 this for a
long time and I I didn't truly really
believe in God until about maybe seven
eight years ago I thought I was a smart
ass and thought you know atheist blah
blah blah and then
gold starts showing himself to me in
many ways whichever religion he's from
but then I realized that people need
something to believe in all these people
who are atheists they're they're they
believe in climate change and abortion
law and covid more than anybody else
they have their beliefs they have their
religions liberalism and their religion
is a religion of absolute degeneracy you
know like look at the things they
purport look at how hard they tried to
convince the world that it's a good idea
that we eat the bugs and and climate
change and that people change gender and
all this other garbage so everyone needs
something higher to believe in and I
think that these
I mean I correct me if I'm wrong is
Islam is not even as old as Christianity
right it's not even that old is it
well it goes a little deeper if if I can
just take a second and kind of run it
down to you see what we believe is that
you have the first man Adam and he was
told to submit his will to the Creator
alone without Associates not to worship
a stick a stone a bone or anything
creation so we believe that Islam
started with the first man Adam then
that concept of submission to the will
of one and only one God not worshiping
your desires not worshiping a human
being anything in creation was the same
way of life that was preached and
teached
with every messenger that God Almighty
sent and from Abraham Noah Moses you
name it all many of the biblical
prophets they all call their people to
worship one and only one God and to
submit their will like the Lord's Prayer
you hear the Lord's Prayer Oh Our Father
who art in heaven Hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come thy will be done we say
this is Islam so just like at that time
if Abraham was asked if he ever heard
this term human he was a human but he
never heard the or human that term human
uh but now if if he was a human he was
same thing if you there's a verse in the
Quran where God Almighty is saying
Abraham Abraham he wasn't a Jew or a
Christian but he was one who submitted
his will to God Almighty that's what a
Muslim is because people get that's why
uh these defining these terms is so
important because you know you think
Muslim you think an Arab in a desert
you'll think Islam it's like some
religion just it's a new religion that
started with Muhammad no no we say it
started with the first man Adam it
continued with Moses is Abraham Jesus
peace be upon him they all call people
to Islam to submit your will to the will
of God and they were all Muslims they
were all ones who submitted their will
to one and only one God you know it's
it's a simple it's very simple to
understand very very you know and then
when you mention uh God it's it goes
with the innate nature there's a
beautiful verse in the Quran where it's
it's uh it's 112th chapter where it says
say he is God the one and only the the
unique the Eternal he begets not nor is
he begotten meaning that he's not born
of of anyone nor does he die he doesn't
have children a DNA of zip code an area
code no uh and there's nothing
comparable to him nothing nothing if you
you cannot compare anyone or anything to
God this is the pure monotheism this is
what distinguishes Islam for every other
ism is the pure monotheism
so I hope I answered your question so we
say it's not a new religion started with
my Muhammad it's just the finality he
was just the final messenger uh
completing it with the the living
miracle that we have today which is the
Quran because Jesus at his time to prove
he was a messenger he did certain
Miracles uh and but if you were to ask
an atheist Today Show me those Miracles
you couldn't show him uh but we believe
in them but today anyone who tastes a
scientific analytical approach they will
see from the preservation of the Quran
to the prophecies you know to many of
the scientific statement there's you
know the the literary Miracle of the
Quran you know there's just too many
things that it doesn't add up that this
would come from a human just a human
being so it's not blind faith in Islam
you take you use the faculties that God
Almighty gave you you look into the
Quran you look into the life of prophet
Muhammad and then like myself and Manny
you're like uh-uh this is not possible
this can come from a human being and
then you submit do you have a lot of
Christians who who convert or change do
you have that along because you can go
and watch you know I got hundreds I've
been doing this since uh early 2000 we
got hundreds and hundreds of uh programs
with people I have a good friend he's
from Romania he's uh jibril Romani
Gabriel Romani uh he's somebody who was
a a Christian and he accepted Islam you
have tons of tons of tons of stories of
people same thing who are struggling
with with many of the uh concepts of God
that are out there
um and and then they looked into they
looked into all the different different
religions like myself and they saw that
Islam just made the most sense like
you're saying the things that it fixed
the problems you know of society gave
Solutions not only on how to go to the
from the smallest things from how to go
to the bathroom to how to run your home
and how to run a country everything is
laid out and it doesn't make sense that
this human being could have came up with
these things you know yeah it's true
it's absolutely it's absolutely
interesting and that's where the base of
my faith comes from my my respect for it
all fifty dollars one hundred dollars
two hundred dollars assalamualaikum
brothers and sisters for the amount that
you would spend on a t-shirt a pair of
pants or some shoes which will
eventually wear out put your investment
in the D Center won't a Masjid and mega
dawa Center they'll bless your wealth in
this life and Hereafter and for future
generations to come we need your help to
raise 395 000 by December 31st and I
know with your help and support
inshallah we can do it click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of you
foreign
[Music]
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum